Nasze najlepsze klasyczne superkomputery stają się coraz potężniejsze,
i coraz lepiej radzimy sobie z obliczeniami, w tym z symulowaniem układów.
Ale symulowanie natury to generalnie bardzo trudny problem.
Mam na imię Victoria Lipinska i dziś przyjrzymy się jednemu z algorytmów,
który mógłby umożliwić symulowanie natury na komputerze kwantowym.
Zacznijmy od przykładu i weźmy pod lupę kofeinę.
To prosta cząsteczka.
Żeby przedstawić konfigurację energetyczną jednej cząsteczki kofeiny,
potrzebowalibyśmy około dziesięć do potęgi 48 bitów.
To dziesięć z 48 zerami
i to około 10% liczby atomów na Ziemi.
I sytuacja jest jeszcze gorsza.
Jeśli masz 125 orbitali i chcesz zapisać wszystkie możliwe
konfiguracje, potrzebujesz więcej pamięci
w klasycznym komputerze niż jest atomów we wszechświecie.
Superkomputery nie są w stanie tego odwzorować.
Jest jednak nadzieja w komputerach kwantowych,
bo z natury świetnie nadają się do symulowania przyrody.
Dla cząsteczki kofeiny oznaczałoby to odwzorowanie
układu przy użyciu 160 qubitów.
To brzmi o wiele bardziej osiągalnie.
Zaproponowano różne algorytmy kwantowe, które pozwalają
mniejszym komputerom kwantowym heurystycznie symulować naturę.
Wchodzi na scenę: wariacyjny solver własny albo VQE.
VQE to algorytm, który działa częściowo na komputerze kwantowym,
a częściowo na klasycznym komputerze.
Pozwala nam znajdować wartości rozwiązujące dany problem optymalizacyjny.
VQE jest bardzo blisko spokrewniony z innymi metodami opartymi na
wariacji parametrów, jak kwantowy algorytm przybliżonej optymalizacji.
Znalezienie zastosowań VQE w twojej branży lub badaniach
to trochę sztuka, ale są pewne ogólne wskazówki.
Generalnie VQE nadaje się do problemów, które można sformułować
jako problem optymalizacyjny ze zmiennymi ciągłymi.
Tak jest na przykład w dużej części chemii kwantowej.
Bardzo często w chemii interesuje nas stan podstawowy.
Stan podstawowy to stan o najniższej energii układu.
Żeby znaleźć energię stanu podstawowego, VQE bada
energię dla różnych konfiguracji układu
i szuka konfiguracji o najniższej energii.
Na wysokim poziomie VQE przyjmuje opis układu kwantowego
i szuka najniższej energii.
Robi to, zmieniając konfigurację układu.
Na początku musimy podać odpowiedni opis układu,
który komputer kwantowy rozumie, oraz zestaw parametrów go opisujących,
które będą optymalizowane.
Kwantowa część
algorytmu przygotowuje układ w stanie
opisanym przez dany zestaw parametrów i oblicza energię.
Natomiast klasyczna część jest odpowiedzialna
za optymalizację tych parametrów na każdym kroku.
Ten kwantowo-klasyczny proces jest powtarzany
do momentu osiągnięcia najniższej energii.
Przyjrzyjmy się teraz bliżej temu, co dzieje się pod maską.
Konfiguracja energetyczna jest zazwyczaj opisana w Hamiltonianie,
który zwykle jest bardzo dużą macierzą.
W algebrze, żeby znaleźć najmniejszą wartość własną macierzy
odpowiadającą najniższej energii układu,
po prostu wykonalibyśmy rozkład według wartości osobliwych.
Jednak macierze, którymi się zajmujemy, są wykładniczo duże
i wykonanie tego algebraicznie to problem o wykładniczej złożoności.
Ten Hamiltonian musi być przedstawiony w formie
zrozumiałej dla komputera kwantowego.
Czyli przetłumaczony z języka chemii na język informatyki kwantowej.
Nie martw się jednak o szczegóły.
Ostatecznie istnieją programowalne sposoby tłumaczenia Hamiltonianu, zwykle
spotykanego w chemii, na Hamiltonian zrozumiały dla komputera kwantowego.
Następnie wprowadzamy ten
Hamiltonian razem z circuit, który nazywamy formą wariacyjną.
Wybór formy wariacyjnej to trochę sztuka.
I znowu,
reprezentuje naszą najlepszą hipotezę o tym, jakim stanem kwantowym może być układ.
Ten wariacyjny circuit jest sparametryzowany zestawem parametrów theta,
a my podajemy też początkowy wybór tych parametrów.
Na tej podstawie kwantowa część VQE:
przygotowuje stan referencyjny, na przykład stan zerowy;
używa sparametryzowanego quantum circuit, czyli formy wariacyjnej, żeby przygotować kwantowy
stan dla początkowego zgadnięcia parametrów na komputerze kwantowym; i szacuje
energię odpowiadającą stanowi ocenionemu przez Hamiltonian.
To oszacowanie energii jest następnie przekazywane
do klasycznego optymalizatora, który znajduje nowy zestaw parametrów.
Parametry wracają z powrotem do kwantowego solvera,
i cały proces jest powtarzany.
Komputer kwantowy wyznacza nowe oszacowanie energii,
klasyczny optymalizator znajduje nowy zestaw parametrów i tak dalej.
Powtarzamy ten proces aż do osiągnięcia zbieżności rozwiązania.
Tzn. dopóki różnica wyników między krokami nie będzie wystarczająco mała
dla naszych potrzeb.
Na koniec algorytm zwraca tę zminimalizowaną energię.
Okej, to świetnie.
Ale możesz się zastanawiać, skąd wiemy, że to naprawdę działa
i że przypadkowo nie znajdziemy energii niższej niż szukana?
To świetne pytanie.
Okazuje się, że nigdy nie możemy oszacować energii niższej.
To zasługa czegoś, co nazywamy zasadą wariacyjną.
Zasada wariacyjna mówi, że największe dolne
ograniczenie energii układu to zawsze jego
najniższa energia odpowiadająca stanowi podstawowemu.
Oznacza to, że energia oceniona dla dowolnego innego stanu tego układu
będzie zawsze większa niż najniższa energia.
Dlatego z VQE nigdy nie możemy otrzymać czegoś
niższego niż energia stanu podstawowego.
Możemy jednak rzeczywiście osiągnąć zbieżność do czegoś
większego niż szukane minimum.
To bywa nazywane rozwiązaniem metastabilnym
i to wyzwanie, z którym badacze zmagają się na co dzień.
VQE jest użyteczny, bo używa płytszych circuits
w porównaniu do innych protokołów pozwalających szacować energię stanu podstawowego.
To sprawia, że nadaje się do bliskiej perspektyw kwantowej.
W tym filmie rzuciliśmy okiem na to, co VQE potrafi i jak jest zbudowany.
Ale zachęcam cię do eksplorowania Qiskit w tym kontekście.
Nawet jeśli jesteśmy jeszcze na początku naszej kwantowej podróży,
możesz już teraz znaleźć to przydatne przy problemach, które próbujesz rozwiązać.
Mam na imię Victoria Lipinska i to był przegląd
algorytmu wariacyjnego solvera własnego.